i just burned my esophagus
my name is george mose and i eat
hamburgers i eat
a lot of hamburgers and i eat hamburgers
so that i can learn about hamburgers and
then teach you about hamburgers i want
you to be as excited about hamburgers as
i am what i'm about to show you is one
of my favorite things from one of my
favorite places this is the gum
cheeseburger say with me gum
cheeseburger gum cheeseburger
it's not spelt the way you think it
would be the gum
cheese
burger
got your attention didn't it when you
try this thing if you're looking for a
gum cheeseburger likely you're at sahara
coast in columbus indiana it's like a a
cheesy sloppy joe it's not really a
hamburger technically it's in the
hamburger family did it descend from the
loose meat sandwich
is it the original sloppy joe or is it a
distant cousin of new york's famous
chopped cheese sandwich whatever the
hell it is it is a perfect marriage of
beef and cheese are you ready to go back
in time all the way back
120 years let's do this
so like the loose meat sandwich we're
gonna basically crumble beef the
difference is we're gonna be adding
spices and a little bit of sauce to make
it gummy or sticky
gummy
gom we found out is an old dutch slang
word for sticky
in indiana
the sloppy joe is sometimes referred to
as a dutch hamburger
as a dutch hamburger did you hear that
did you do the math do the math do the
math
that's the kind of stuff that excites me
on burger scholar sessions is to put
those things together if you think we're
done with this [ __ ] no you're wrong i
got plenty more of this [ __ ] up my
sleeve
[Music]
a little bit olive oil some diced onions
meat and pan
fat draining
that's hot no don't touch that [ __ ]
idiot
no
we're not gonna oh [ __ ] we've been done
here
brain's broken brain's broken
okay
got it okay i got a couple of spices
here this is chili spices onion powder
garlic powder you obviously need some
salt in there a little bit of salt
to make it happy
and i'm going to add some water kind of
making a chili
paste out of this right sugar you have
the brown sugar goes into
the gum for sure i'm almost positive of
that but i'm pretty sure that there is
some molasses
in the gum
as well
worcestershire
see what's happening it's getting sticky
sticky sticky
oh
damn it
well the tide stick the first thing you
notice when you walk into sahara coast
is that you're dressed incorrectly
because no one
looks like they're from this century at
all and in the back of the restaurant
there's an original welte orchestrion
player organ that is cranking out loud
turn of the century music zaharicos is
full of treasures i have a few of my own
antiques and treasures but you want to
see them
this is one of the very first 16
millimeter cameras it's a cine kodak
model k
1930.
awesome it still works listen and we'll
crank it up here
hear that 20 years ago when i made
hamburger america the movie my friends
at ted steam cheeseburgers gave me a
steaming box how cool is that even
little things inside little
little trays for steaming meat and
cheese oh check it out this is my
original
1980s santa cruz bullet board complete
with black flag and grateful dead
stickers
and i was told by george powell don't
ever ride that thing again he's right
don't ever write that again oh and
oh you know this is
that's right it's an r2d2 piggy bank
1977 a gift from my dad for christmas
back to burgers
i just burned my esophagus oh yeah
the next step
in the gum
is to add cheese
we're gonna make a gum cheeseburger
ready for this one this is pretty basic
cheese goes into the pan that's it
cheese in the pan what's gonna happen
now though cheese is gonna start to melt
and make a mess
into the toaster goes the bread good
thing these this is a very fast toaster
so
there we go
[ __ ] oh no burning oh god all right
okay one piece of toast
there we go
some
oh gum cheese
i see how cool it is it stays together
second piece of toast on top
oh my god
not a hamburger
but it's squarely in the hamburger
family
if not the recipe
i'll tell you right now
that's pretty damn close
it's ridiculously good
hmm
[Music]
ah that's good
it takes me back 120 years we almost
lost a haircut okay
one guy
named tony moravec saved zaharakos from
its imminent demise after years of going
into decline the restaurant was a mess
and the family sold the restaurant to
tony moravec the owner of a company
called boudreau's butt paste that's
right
that guy the guy that made every baby
rash better
is this not the american dream a guy
makes a fortune on baby rash ointment
and takes his money and saves an
american soda fountain that happens to
have an iconic hamburger sandwich on the
menu
you should be honored by america he is
an american hero
sorry
actually that's how i feel by the way
i'm sorry i'm getting a little little
i'm shaking i'm shaking the guy didn't
have to do that he did not have to do
that
it costs a lot of money i don't think
he'll ever make that money back i think
he's aware he'll never make that money
back what he did though
he preserved a piece of america you walk
into zaherakos you're walking into
tony's dream i'll see you next time when
i connect even more dots in this crazy
patchwork of hamburger history
i can't get enough
[Music]
hi i'm george moats from burger scholar
sessions don't forget to like and
subscribe and watch more episodes right
here
somewhere here
right here
up in here